[Música]
[Aplausos]
dicen que quien no conoce su historia
está condenado a repetirla pero ese no
es el caso de las mujeres de la familia
gafas verán mi abuela nació el 22 de
noviembre de 1933 en la vereda de tul
antad perteneciente al municipio de
pamplonita aquí en el norte de santander
fue la aparición mayor de cinco hermanos
y al ser la única niña desde muy
temprana edad tuvo que asumir labores
muy pesadas como por ejemplo recoger
café hacer el almuerzo y llevar solo a
los obreros de la finca y cuidar a sus
hermanos menores
un día mi abuela llegó de recoger café y
yo que uno de sus primos que
recientemente había enviudado estaba
hablando con sus padres al poco tiempo
tuvo que casarse con él
él le doblaba la edad y ella no
solamente tenía que hacerse cargo de los
hijos que surgieran de ese matrimonio
sino de los hijos huérfanos de madre del
primer matrimonio de mi abuela
durante los primeros años de casada de
mi abuela ella decidió convencer a todas
las mujeres de la vereda que sí tenían
opción de elegir no se casara recuerda
con mucha tristeza cuando le dijo a su
mejor amiga que si podía elegir no se
casara que no lo hiciera
porque con mucha tristeza porque su
mejor amiga parecía que puedes hacer la
primera comunión ese día porque tan solo
tenía 13 años también intento hacer lo
mismo con su hijastra pero cada vez que
lo intentaba solo recibía señalamientos
y rechazos entonces y ahora tomo una
decisión
ella con mi abuelo tuvo 12 hijos de esos
12 hijos días fueron niñas y dos hombres
decidió mandar a sus hijas a cualquier
casco urbano fuera pamplonita
bucaramanga pamplona o cúcuta con algún
pariente con sus hijastros que ya eran
adultos para ese entonces con sus
hermanos para que sus hijas no corrieran
con la misma suerte que ella corrió
mi abuela le sudaban las manos rezaba
cada vez que alguna de mis tías le
presentaba un novio para que aquellos
noviazgos no terminaran en matrimonios
mi mamá es la séptima hija de los dos
hermanos mi mamá desde los 15 años
empezó a trabajar como niñera de
muchísimos niños de hecho todavía lo es
y hacer aseo en casas ajenas ella llegó
hasta el séptimo grado a duras penas mi
mamá a los 28 años queda embarazada y
queda totalmente aterrada porque pensaba
que su familia la iba a rechazar y que
sus patrones la iban a echar de su
trabajo
así que un día un domingo decidió
contarles a sus hermanos que estaba
embarazada mis tíos por aquel entonces
tenían la costumbre de ir a la calle del
amor en cúcuta al barrio la cabrera a la
calle de la morcilla así que mientras
ese día ellos tomaban cerveza y comían
morcilla les contó que estaba embarazada
y ellos contrario a todo lo que ella
esperaba resultaron a reír le dijeron
que tranquila que ellos iban a cuidar de
esa bebé
del mismo modo le contó a sus patrones
que estaba embarazada y ellos le dijeron
que tranquila que podía seguir
trabajando con ellos y decidieron
afiliar la a lo que en ese entonces se
conocía como el seguro social
fui educada por un profesor y una
secretaria que trabajaron en colegios
públicos de cúcuta ellos me criaron como
hija propia
hasta en ese momento ya están
pensionados pero mi mamá estaba muy
preocupada porque yo creciera en una
burbuja porque se me olvidará mis raíces
porque rechazara mi origen así que toda
mi primera infancia transcurrió entre el
campo y la ciudad mi mamá me obligaba a
ir donde mi abuela
e incluso después de que nos fuimos
definitivamente de la finta pasé mucho
en un trayecto tenía yo nueve años
mi abuela mi mamá perdón me llevó a
conocer a unos amigos que vivían en un
páramo que se conocía como el altico
dicho trayecto costaba de dos horas a
pie cuando llegamos que tenía muchísimas
ganas de ir al baño mi mamá me dijo que
ellos no tenían baño yo no podía creerlo
cómo era posible que estas personas
pudieran vivir sin tener un baño
entonces mi mamá me contó que cuando
ella era niña ellos tenían letrinas y
que a veces cuando las ganas les ganaban
al cuerpo les tocaba hacer donde fuera y
efectivamente como presagio en el camino
de regreso las ganas me sorprendieron en
el monte
desde ese momento salí de mi zona de
confort y empecé a tomarle un poco de
cariño a todo lo rural
esto estudiar la escuela normal superior
maría auxiliadora porque mis padres de
crianza y mi mamá querían que fuera
maestra
me negué
porque no voy a soportar dos años más
bajo el régimen de las monjas
así que cuando llegó el momento de
elegir mi carrera estudié comunicación
social a regañadientes
porque porque no había presupuesto para
estudiar en otra universidad ni mucho
menos vivir por fuera de cúcuta confieso
que al principio odiaba mi carrera no me
gustaba la tomaba con matrimonio a la
fuerza luego cuando conocí la radio me
enamoré por completo así que es como en
el 2015 presenté un proyecto al
ministerio de cultura para trabajar en
una emisora comunitaria en tibasosa
boyacá en radio se me lees en qué
consistía ese proyecto consistía en
fortalecer las prácticas lectoras y
escritoras de un grupo de niños
campesinos para la creación de
contenidos de su programa radial
infantil confieso que me enamoré de la
vida rural boyacense y que la banda
sonora de jorge velosa contribuyó a ese
romance
tiempo después fui docente rural en el
urabá antioqueño
la vereda el colegio quedaba bastante
distante del casco urbano de hecho la
hacienda de la que fue el líder de las
auc de las autodefensas unidas de
colombia quedaba media hora del colegio
y yo tenía que vivir con una de mis
estudiantes porque me quedaba muy lejos
del pueblo el papá de una de mis
estudiantes era desmovilizado del bloque
de medellín de las aulas
entre aguaceros antioqueños mi visión
del conflicto del país creció y creció
muchísimo
así que puedo haber conocido mucho de
boyacá y antioquia
pero muy poco del norte de santander así
que después de enviar tantas hojas de
vida y por azares del destino llegué a
trabajar un territorio que solo queda
tres horas de aquí y que siempre quise
conocer
la zona del catatumbo en norte de
santander catatumbo en lengua varia y
traduce casa de trueno
el catatumbo es un río es uno de los más
grandes afluentes del norte de santander
que desemboca en el lago de maracaibo
marcando la frontera con venezuela y es
una zona muy rica en recursos naturales
muy importantes para la economía del
país como los hidrocarburos el cacao y
la palma y también con una fauna y flora
bastante exótica entre gavillas
armadillos culebras y serpientes un día
en mi trabajo
estábamos pasando por un puente de la
vereda de caño indio que queda en la
zona rural de tibú que se llama caño
indio porque hay muchas fuentes de agua
que la gente reconoce como pequeños
caños y una de las niñas de la variedad
me dijo venga y mira que hay aquí yo fui
extrañado de que pues porque la niña que
quería que hubiera e insistió venga y se
agachó y mira que hay aquí entonces me
agaché y entre las rendijas del puente
claro que los puentes son bastante
rudimentarios porque no tienen baranda
solo son un conjunto de tablas había una
culebra bastante gruesa descansando
reposando entre las rendijas del puente
pero yo no me asusté ya no me sorprendí
la niña quedó bastante extrañado porque
para ellos es normal que una persona que
viene de afuera a trabajar en la vereda
se sorprenda con ese tipo de situaciones
que para ellos son bastante cómodas para
nadie es un secreto que el catatumbo ha
sido protagonista en el conflicto de
colombia porque en el año 1990 2005
varias masacres se llevaron a cabo en
este lugar y hubo presencia del bloque
33 de las farc y del bloque catatumbo de
las auc de hecho todavía
época de compost conflicto las noticias
registran presencia de grupos al margen
de la ley como el pl y el el en el que
consiste mi trabajo mi trabajo se trata
de hacer fortalecimiento familiar de una
forma pedagógica con las familias que
viven en la vereda
hacemos algo como una indagación en el
árbol genealógico de cada familia
y es muy común ver como las historias se
repiten por ejemplo si una mamá tuvo
varias parejas en su vida es muy común
es muy probable que su hija tenga varias
parejas por ejemplo si la mamá fue madre
adolescente es muy probable que la niña
también sea madre adolescente los niños
de caño indio tienen una escuela que
queda ahora es el camino que por ejemplo
cuando llueve mucho en el caso del
catatumbo cuyas tormentas y aguaceros
son un espectáculo visual pero bastante
perturbador para quienes le tenemos
miedo a los truenos
las calles las calles no el camino de
trocha se hace intransitable por el bar
y cuando hace muchísimo calor los niños
llegan con dolor de cabeza por las
largas horas de camino para llegar a la
escuela y esa escuela solo tiene hasta
quinto grado eso no es muy común la
deserción escolar por ende las niñas no
pues no tienen oportunidad de terminar
su bachillerato porque el colegio más
cercano que tenga secundaria que ha
sobre la vía hacia la gabarra en vetas o
algunas tienen que trasladarse a tibú y
eso una de cada diez
a mí me da el mismo pánico que le daba a
mi abuela cuando le permitía
representaban a los novios mi edad
cuando veo un hombre mayor rondando la
escuela y mirando las niñas de cuarto
grado y de quinto grado
porque se cree y es afectado socialmente
por la comunidad que una mujer para
alcanzar un estatus social especialmente
en la zona rural tiene que conseguir
marido que sólo así puede tener una
mejor calidad de vida
pero yéndonos un poco a estadísticas de
cómo está el panorama de la mujer rural
en colombia
según informa el semanal de las 25 500
mil 149 millones de mujeres que hay
conmigo en colombia 5 millones 442 mil
241 viven en la zona rural de esa cifra
el 37.4 por ciento viven en situación de
pobreza y realizan labores domésticas y
agrícolas
y según un estudio de la universidad de
los andes seis de cada diez colombianos
no están de acuerdo con cambiar los
roles de género en el campo el panorama
de las niñas del catatumbo no se
diferencia mucho de la época en la que
vivió mi abuela
pero volviendo a la historia de mi
familia cada vez que estamos en la
cocina de la casa
reflexionando porque vivimos 12 personas
en una casa sobre las decisiones de mi
abuela concluimos que si no hubiese sido
por esa decisión de ella de haber
enviado a sus hijas a diferentes lugares
mis mis tías muy probablemente estarían
como las mujeres del catatumbo viviendo
en una casa de tablas con techo de zinc
o techo de palmas llenas de hijos y con
un desgaste físico notoria
en el año de 1997 mi familia dejó
definitivamente el campo mis tías me
cuentan que el trasteo fue bastante
difícil para ellas ese día llovió
muchísimo y llevaron llenaron de
costales y bajaron por el camino real o
la trocha un camión y ellas iban tomando
y llorando porque les costaba mucho
dejar su tierra natal cuando llegaron al
barrio llegaron a una casa de cuatro
habitaciones en obra negra y ley y ellos
bajaron del camión patos pollos gallinas
conejos y los vecinos se quedaron
extraña dijimos qué clase de familia
había llegado al barrio hoy en día esa
casa tiene las suficientes habitaciones
y la mejor infraestructura para albergar
a 12 personas y todo eso gracias al
esfuerzo y trabajo de mi mamá de mis
tías y mi abuela
esta foto fue tomada aproximadamente en
el año de 1965 la niña más pequeña es mi
mamá
y bueno tres niñas y un niño ella es mi
tía
mide 80 a los 11 años
tuvo que irse a trabajar a la ciudad
a duras penas terminó la primaria e hizo
su bachillerato en la nocturna
su primer trabajo formal fue en la
cafetería el mundo al revés
porque efectivamente hacía todo al revés
mi tía desde muy pequeña demostró que no
era apta para la vida del campo lloraba
todo el tiempo se espantaba con los
animales le daba miedo caminar sola
estar sola y hoy en día es una
profesional en una papelería y es
especialista en todo lo que tiene que
ver con copias con indumentaria de papel
viviana por su parte ella llegó hasta el
noveno grado más o menos y se pueda
bogotá estudiar en una academia de
belleza
cuidando niños logro pagarse este
estudio lleva más de 30 años trabajando
en una de las peluquerías más antiguas
de cúcuta hace algún tiempo ella se
encontró con un amor de su vida y
decidió irse a vivir con él
y cada vez que puede que el bolsillo lo
permite viajar a cualquier parte del
país
vitoria por su parte ella empezó a
trabajar desde muy pequeña y trabajó en
una cacharrería de la ciudad en los años
70 y en los años 80 tiempos que fueron
de prosperidad económica para cúcuta
ella aprendió a coser ella misma se
hacía sus trajes con pantalones
acampanados a la cintura y sus conjuntos
pero en 1987 cuando muere mi abuelo mi
tía toma la decisión de tomar las
riendas de la finca ella actualmente es
la columna vertebral del hogar y lo
sigue siendo
como verán tres de mis días ellas tres
no se casaron no tuvieron hijos y
probablemente rompieron con todo lo que
se aprobaron ha pronosticado con su
historia es decir que se esperaba de
ellas se quedarán en la finca que
tuvieran hijos y que se quedarán
trabajando en el campo pero no gracias a
esta decisión de mi abuela la historia y
el hilo de la historia se rompe
soy una mujer que hace parte soy yo soy
una persona que hace parte de una
generación de mujeres pues puede decidir
por sí misma he tenido muchas
oportunidades y privilegios que ni mi
abuela ni mi mamá y mis tías tuvieron
puede ir a una universidad he recorrido
quisimos lugares de este país todo
gracias a la decisión de mi abuela que
no fue una decisión por sus hijas sino
también fue una decisión por todas las
generaciones de mujeres que vienen en
nuestra familia por eso asumo con amor
ese sacrificio y me pregunto qué puedo
hacer por las mujeres que vienen detrás
de mí no me refiero solamente a las
mujeres de la familia sino aquellas
niñas y adolescentes que viven en zonas
apartadas del país que merecen igualdad
de oportunidades
hoy estoy aquí hoy a mis 25 años estoy
aquí parada contando su historia y
agradezco muchísimo a mi abuela que
precisamente ayer cumple 85 años y que
está acá presente en el público por
haberme contado su historia por haberme
hecho testigo de aquellos momentos y
anécdotas cada vez que se iba a la luz
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]